[Musik]
ja möchte ich stolz bin ich wenn jemand
vielleicht Mini gekannt hat ich bin da
an die Holzer einer von zwei blinden
Profi Bergsteigen weltweit der erste
blinde Mensch
Pichler aus dem österreichischen
Clemens und auf der Seite sitzt die
Initialzündung der heutigen Tour des
Projekts
ich sag mir zugekommen schon vorher über
einem Jahr und war fasziniert und hat
einfach von ganz wenigen Menschen
hineinschauen wollen ist sowas
interessantes in der blinden Welt oder
es ist da
jetzt Egerländer Kante Dolomiten 12 14
zeilingen Wetter ziemlicher Challenge
mein Freund Ulf
ja der hat sich eingelassen
und der erste Schritt ist einmal ultra
damit du in meine Welt geratest er lässt
sich echt auf das sein man sieht jetzt
anscheinend nichts machen
von meinem Freund
Ulf
dass sie einen Tag mit euch zwei
verbringen mit dem linken an die Hölzer
an der Holzer ist ein langjähriger
Freund von mir und mir zwar eigenartiges
erlebniskopf und zwar
für unsere
begleiten dürfen auf den höchsten Berg
dieser Welt der Mann
48 Metern und jetzt bin ich wieder mal
so viel miteinander unterwegs und jetzt
ist die nächste Session jetzt begleite
den Andi und den Ulf
sozusagen eine zweite blinde Person
dabei der versucht Egerländer Kante
heute im blinden nachsteigen miteinander
zu machen ich bin grundsätzlich ein
kleinerer Punkt ich sichere nur und dann
ist die Hauptperson die was in Ulf
anleitet wir blinder klettert
Bergführer bin hat es ist es mir
ermöglicht worden als eiersbergführer
eben diese Expedition miteinander zu
machen
[Musik]
immer die Spitzen zu Klassen keine
ellbogene Strecken keine Knie heiße
Strecken und die Finger immer noch
[Musik]
sorry
durchgezogen knallhart hat nie
geschwindelt unglaublich für mich eine
Wertschätzung ohne Ende das Auto
überhaupt macht sich so lange zu
versetzen kann man nicht vergleichen ich
bin von Geburt an blind der Ulf ist seit
drei Stunden blind Ulf erzähl mir
wenigsten
[Musik]
die du hättest jetzt noch dem Projekt
bist du jetzt glücklich oder wie was
geht in dein Gott vor
fertig
das letzte Dings der wollte sich Sachen
also das Wahre ist wesentlich leichter
dass die Koordination noch Lust
also es wird eigentlich niemals möchte
ich sagen
darf
die weite Welt wird deswegen
[Musik]
ist wirklich für mich
zwischenmenschliche Kommunikation was in
unserer Zivilisation verloren gegangen
ist es ist ja schon gar nicht mal schick
wenn man jemand noch etwas fragt und
deswegen voneinander abhängig zu sein
ist die dunkel den Scheiße sondern es
kann eigentlich ja ganzer gewaltiges
auch sein so bei mir drei Tage klettert
sein hat jeder gewusst
ich brauch den anderen bin ich weg bin
1700 m aneinander
Organismus und genauso war das halt
die Klappe
ich glaube dass das denn sehen oder den
quasi normalen Menschen aber es gibt
also schaut mal hier der tut sich
deshalb anders herum es war blinde
aufsteigt aber da immer wieder mit da
kommt was zurück was du mir das sehenden
Partner
vielleicht sagen was der Unterschied ist
wenn er mit mir klettert ich bin jetzt
sehr geburtsblender
[Gelächter]
ja das das ist ja unabhängig davon
vielleicht kennt man sagen ist auf dem
Abwechslung weil es ist ja mit jedem
Kletterpartner wo sie haben oder als
Bergführer jeden klettergast wo sie so
führen muss ist jeder anders
wie wenn jetzt mit Ulf als sehen
klettern würde und ich glaube für mich
persönlich ist es eine Abwechslung
mit dir zu gehen zum Beispiel weil
die Führungstechnik muss man bei dir
anwenden muss oder soll brauche
mir der Clemens dass ich mich vom Seil
ausbinde und Seil frei weitergeht das
kann schon normal es ist schwierig genau
schlechter sondern es ist drin
das Vertrauen
das einfach die Verantwortung jeder
selber hat nicht immer der Clemens ist
Schuld für alles hat wenn du irgendwas
passiert das ist ein ganzer geiler Punkt
in unseren zusammen sein überhaupt dass
man endlich haben alle verfluchte
Verantwortung selber nehmen in unserer
Gesellschaft muss immer anderer Schuld
seiner zuständig sein das lernen wir von
der volksschulweg die Wahrheit besteht
selber vielleicht Glück im Leben
Verantwortung verantwortlich und das
wäre schon auch ein konsumieren und
deswegen hat der Ulf wahrscheinlich sich
das angetan und komplett andere
Bandbreite zu kriegen oder was denkst du
eine abhängiger
schon eine langjährige Verbindung
bergführergehilfen hochtönergang ich
glaube 1 August war es Rudolfshütte
Rudolfshütte Wintereinbruch schnell und
meine die ganze Prüfung sein hat meine
Handschuhe komplett neu gewesen und ich
war beim Clemens an und normalerweise
ist dann die Ausbildung immer die coolen
und sagen bald oder
die Handschuhe ausgezogen
ist immer der was von klein auf das
Spiel einfach so immer geschaut hat
haben die anderen und das Kind immer
wieder durch das ist sowas echt es gibt
halt immer
[Musik]
das Gespräch dahinten Design gefilmt
habe das Projekt begleitet eigentlich
mit der Kamera also mit einem Handy und
mit einer Family gehen
natürlich heißt das erlebt und einfach
erlebt wie ich eigentlich nicht
Bergsteiger jetzt da am Felsen noch
gegriffen suchen nach dritten sucht ja
und die zwei hinter mir die Wochen das
der Ultra braucht da natürlich
aufgezogen gehabt
der verwalkt mit dem Fersen wird die
Finger und mit die vierste verwackst
einfach mit dem das ist ja Wahnsinn
gewesen ja totale Sicherheit für sich
also wenn der den Tritt setzt dann sitzt
der dritt wenn jemand anderes
Sicherheit da war jeder hat jedes jeder
Griff und da jeder an der jeder dreht
hat gepasst die muss sagen ich bin echt
beeindruckt
[Musik]